you see what we deny as a culture as a
culture of materialist positivist
reductionists is the presence of spirit
in the world in ourselves or in nature
and so Western science is very concerned
to deny what is called Tilos Telos is a
greek term for purpose purpose the same
idea as the attractor that I was trying
if you have a target if you're driving a
car toward a goal the goal is your Tilos
it decides how you will steer the car
well it has been for the past hundred
and fifty years extremely fashionable in
sociology and biology because of Darwin
to deny Tilos in nature to say that you
know any apparent order in nature is
made up of the disorder of random
mutation meeting the disorder of natural
selective processes and these two
streams of converging disorder create a
kind of a parent or virtual order which
is an illusion this is the Orthodox
theory and when you take this Darwinism
and put it into historical theory theory
of human processes in time you get the
modern position in academic philosophy
about history which is that it is and
the official phrase is trend lessly
fluctuating that's what we are asked to
believe we are embedded in a 10,000 year
old process of trend less fluctuation in
mathematics this is called a random walk
it means you just go over here a few
steps and then you go this way and then
you go about you're like a drunk
lurching around in this face space and
this is the highest vision of human
purpose that the reductionist vision can
offer well
the intuition of religion is especially
Western religion and I wouldn't even
bother to mention it except that it also
is the strong intuition of a lot of
psychedelic experience that there is
some kind of a tractor in the historical
faith space there is something which is
drawing everything toward it it's like a
higher dimensional entity that casts an
enormous shadow over the human landscape
so that you know at sitting around
campfires 50,000 years ago people felt
this vague tug toward organization order
cognitive activity epigenetic activity
of a genetic activity means coding stuff
not in your genes but in dance gesture
ritual and ultimately in clay and on
paper and in electronic storage methods
this proliferation of complexity is a
response to and an anticipation of this
transcendental object at the end of
historical process you see if it weren't
for our presence on this planet even
modern science at its present primitive
state could give a fairly good
accounting of what's going on that out
of complex polymers arose super complex
polymers which were self-replicating and
that was life and then you have an
animal population but the fly in the
ointment of this rational model of
reality is ourselves we are clearly
imbued with a higher dimension which we
call spirit in a way that ordinary
matter when imbued with a higher
dimension is called life in other words
we represent a different ontological
level in the career of organization we
because we hope we despair we plan we
remember and we miss remember you know
we lie we fabricate we delude ourselves
in other way all of these things are
uniquely human functions well I think
that shamanism which is the focus of our
concern here is a kind of anticipating
of the whole pattern and that this is
really the way to think about shamanism
when thinking of it as a force that can
steady and complete an individual human
life the shamans are not in history in
the same way that we are by having
access to this higher dimension that
they go to in their trance States and
their states of intoxication they gain a
fractal overview on process on life I
mean after all isn't that what we mean
by wisdom is wisdom is understanding how
things really work how they really work
love affairs the raising of children the
managing of corporations the prosecution
of wars how do these things really work
not the deluded and fumbling attempts of
the proponents of this or that school
but a Taoist stick insight into the
actual appropriate dynamics of
everything well how do you gain that
kind of an insight it maybe the answer
is you must have a superior model you
must have a superior model now if you
believe you know that the world is
composed of three levels and they are
held up on the back of a woman who sits
on a giant tortoise who floats in space
this is a model of the universe it can
take you a certain distance but what
what model of the universe can
actually offer reassurance in all kinds
of situations well strangely enough I
think that these models come from the
frontiers of mathematics that it is not
near coincidence that the storms of
visionary hallucination that the shaman
encounters are very much like the storms
of form and color that are spewed out of
a Cray 3 supercomputer when it conducts
a thousand iterations per second inside
the Julia set or the mantle brought set
or one of these other compound complex
mathematical objects that we are
beginning to see you see mathematics up
to this point has been a computational
science because mathematicians used
pencils and blackboards and chalk to
describe their objects and consequently
an excruciatingly ly difficult
vocabulary kept most people from
appreciating what mathematics was about
now the computer is too modern
mathematics like the telescope was to
16th century astronomy the computer
becomes a window into domains of hyper
complex computability that previously
could barely even be conceived but that
now at a rate of millions approaching
billions of iterations per second Ralph
works on the mmpp machine the multiple
parallel processing machine at Goddard
Space Flight Center it does 800 mega
flops per second
800 million floating point decimal
calculations per second well you can
dream dreams with a machine like that
and strangely enough at the edge of the
super technology of the Dominator
culture at Goddard Space Flight Center
with guys high priest standing around
in white coats when you get it up and
running what you see is what an
ayahuasca shaman sees on a Saturday
night in the Amazon you see that you are
navigating through a complex higher
dimensional phase space where by varying
the inputs of amplitude and frequency in
one case using an electronic box in the
other case using the human voice you
sing your way through a mathematical
domain which is a higher resonance of
reality and you learn how the world
really works how things happen well how
the hell do they happen well on the
simplest level they happen like this
they have a beginning they have a middle
and then they die away as an oscillation
a damped oscillation now this simple
truth to which we all non descent is in
fact the hardest thing the hardest
swallow there is for the dominator ego
and the Dominator personality because
what this simple truth says things come
into being they achieve their
inflorescence and they fade away is as
Heraclitus put it taunted ray all flows
nothing lasts nothing is saved and this
is you know our glory and our agony that
you know the people we love and the
people we hate are swept away by time
empires dynasties continents are swept
away by time and yet our search for
security is cast in the Dominator
culture as a search for permanence you
know so what we what you do when you do
that is you set yourself at war against
the cosmos which is a heroic stance if
you're if you're trying to produce mal
villian opera out of your life you know
Ahab says in Moby Dick he's talking to
his first mate Starbuck who signifies
Christian right reason he's raving about
going after the whale and he says you
know will chase it over both sides of
Earth and round perdition's flame and
Starbuck says to seek revenge on a dumb
brute seems blasphemy and he says
blasphemy Starbuck speak not to me
of blasphemy I would strike out the Sun
if it insulted me for could it do that
then could I do the other since there is
ever a sort of fair play well you know
this is locker room talk the notion that
there is fair play
between a man and a nearby star is the
finest expression of the Dominator ego I
can imagine and of course you know the
story of Moby Dick can be read on many
levels but finally it is the story of
the submersion of the male ego in the
oceans of the unconscious born to its
destruction and transformation by an
encounter with the maternal matrix in
the form of the vagina dentata of the of
the sperm whale and everything that it's
symbolized so I don't think we want to
go that way I don't think we want to set
ourselves up as the Crusaders for
permanence
but that means softening to the fact of
the flow and of the impermanence
[Music]
you
[Music]